il suffit de réunir dans un même plan du
froid une voiture qui ressemble à un
rectangle en fait ressortir un type à la
mine patibulaire
et une blonde un peu voyante
elle a des talons dans la neige et un
prénom qui se termine en pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les attaques à tamines
homme
qui cultive
walcott à martha si
malines
ici dans ces décors figé propice au
cinéma on reste immobile et on attend
quoi que les salles obscures se
réchauffe et que le cinéma russe
manipuler ou malmenés par le pouvoir se
réveille
[Musique]
instrument de propagande sous lénine
censuré sous staline des gelées à la
pérestroïka est il aujourd'hui sinistré
sous poutine
toutes les bonnes raisons pour réaliser
un voyage inédit à travers les toiles de
la russie
forcément tout commence à moscou
[Musique]
belle riche et décati à la fois avec des
airs tristes deux pays entre deux mondes
[Musique]
une ville où un chef d'état en pleine
campagne électorale n'hésite pas à
s'afficher en grand sur la devanture
d'un énorme multiplex façon ivan le
terrible qui impose clairement que le
cinéma ici c'est une affaire d'état
un état qui se dit prêt à investir
beaucoup d'argent pour relancer son
cinéma en perdition
un bien quand même mal pour cet art
tiraillé à l'image d'un pays qui se
cherche entre le très mauvais cinéma
populaire qui s'écroule et celui d'art
et essai qui peine à se faire une place
[Musique]
oh
avant ce pays immense comptait 22 mille
salles de cinéma
on
aujourd'hui il n'en reste que 1800 en
activité les autres sont fermés
comme celle ci
à l'entrée un gardien à 6 à temps
al étage un homme casquette vissée sur
la tête regarde lui c'est naoum klayman
le directeur du musée du cinéma à moscow
un musée récemment fermé par l'état car
jugées inutiles
[Musique]
vous voyez ici l'une des pyramides d'une
atlantide en cours d'engloutissement
parce que dans le temps on construisait
des énormes salles de cinéma avec plus
de 1000 places et on arrivait à les
remplir
aujourd'hui tout cela n'a plus de sens
le cinéma a changé le rapport au cinéma
a lui aussi changé
et je crains que ce type de ça n'ait
plus d'avenir
comme de cinéma je suis très amer il y
avait ici du très bon matériel comme un
magnifique projecteurs 70 mm par exemple
la grande époque cette salle avait
beaucoup de succès on y montrait des
bons films et les gens venaient de loin
pour voir ici ces films qui ne passait
pas en centre-ville
vous savez je ne suis pas pro fait je
pense que le cinéma ne peut pas résoudre
ces problèmes tout seul
on doit d'abord trouver des solutions
aux problèmes de l'état au puy la
société russe et désorientée elle n'est
pas prête à se reconnaître dans un écran
elle cherche davantage à trouver une
échappatoire abri
alors coincé dans cet état de latence la
majorité des russes goinfre de films
blockbuster américain et de pop corn
dans des multiplexes sans âme tandis que
quelques autres se noient dans des films
passéiste
[Musique]
au milieu d'un parc d'attractions trône
un grand bâtiment rond le kinopanorama
ici depuis 1957 rien n'a changé on y
cultive la grandeur de l'union
soviétique sur douze écrans où sont
projetés en simultané des films
nostalgique à la gloire de ce pays qui
n'existe plus
[Musique]
aux commandes de ce cinéma panoramique
unique au monde de femmes
une blonde
et une brune
irina et natalia tous les jours et même
pour un seul spectateur elle charge avec
fierté les douze projecteurs
[Musique]
on
vous savez je fais ça de manière
mécanique
n'y a absolument rien de sorcier
le fait à toute vitesse c'est devenu une
routine pour moi
la seule chose qu'il faut être très
attentif bien regarder pour ne pas
s'emmêler les pinceaux avec les bobines
il faut rien vérifié le titre du film
et puis le numéro du projecteur
ça fait 20 ans que je travaille ici
depuis 1990
à chaque séance on a un genre de
ministres est ce parce que les problèmes
arrivent toujours par surprise maintenu
jeudi dernier tout allait bien tout
fonctionnait et à la première séance de
dimanche ça ne marchait pas
voilà on a été obligé de tout annuler on
a relancé trois fois de suite les
projecteurs et ça n'a pas marché
[Musique]
oh
quel est le film là que vous allez
projeter les sources intarissables
par deux fois du folklore dans les
quinze républiques soviétiques de
l'enseignent res s
what colonnes les thématiques de ses
films était plutôt variés mais c'est
vrai qu'elle était imaginé pour les
touristes sur leur offrir un panorama
idyllique de l'union soviétique
parce que tous nos films date de cette
époque il fallait que les gens est un
aperçu du pays pour que les touristes
puissent voir comment on vivait en urss
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
discret est hasardeux et n'en est pas
aussi critique au racing pistoles
loughney rockets évoqué des pistes gibbs
[Musique]
ici c'est le tableau de commande de tous
nos projecteurs
de tous les appareils du cinéma
panoramique
[Musique]
on évoque chez tout cas tom avant ce
cinéma était un terrain d'essai pour
toutes les dernières nouveautés c'est
ici contestait les nouveaux équipements
bref tout était neuf alors que
maintenant notre cinéma a l'air d'un
dinosaure
b
toujours
alger sort par le dernier réalisateur de
film panoramique qui est mort ya pas
longtemps était né en 1918 il venait
souvent ici si on bavarde elle n'est pas
beaucoup d'autres cinémas où les
réalisateurs viennent comme ça
comprenez ici c'était particulier y
avait même sa propre pièce où il y avait
une table de montage spécial justement
pour monter ce genre de film
[Musique]
ans
vous devez être fiers de travailler
quand même
en effet ce lieu est légendaire encore
aujourd'hui les gens se montrent
intéressés parce que quand ils viennent
ici soit le passé réapparu devant leurs
yeux soit il le découvre
aujourd'hui les gens sont venus avec
leurs enfants et leurs petits enfants
ils ont regardé les films ils nous ont
remercié à la fin le jeune homme nous a
dit il faudrait tout numériser pour que
cela reste pour les siècles à venir
ce mot la numérisation je n'arrête pas
de l'entendre mais bien sûr si on
numérise est alors le côté rare de la
projection disparaître
un jour ou l'autre inévitablement cela
va disparaître parce que la pellicule
n'est pas éternellement
je pense que ce cinéma et passéiste mais
il ne veut pas renoncer il ne veut pas
mourir on peut considérer qu'il peut
s'estimer heureux d'être encore en état
de marche aujourd'hui
c'est très difficile de s'adapter à
cette nouvelle époque mais moi je vais
au travail avec plaisir oui tout est
vieux mais je peux dire que cela n'est
pas pour me déplaire
[Musique]
du
dans la ville au loin se dresse un
immeuble imposant et magnifique symbole
de la russie de staline le kotel
niscayah
[Musique]
dans cet endroit on y vit on y fait ses
courses et on peut même aller au cinéma
l'illusion c'est l'unique lieu où l'on
peut voir de très vieux films
[Musique]
alors tous les jours pour une poignée de
roubles les vieux moscovites se pressent
ici ils oublient la dure réalité d'un
pays dans lequel et ne se retrouve pas
et quand la séance commence on entend
une seule voix russe qui double un film
américain sous titré en néerlandais
surprenant et insoupçonnable
[Musique]
fait
les choses
franchement
vers paris
nocturne se gagne à bright star de
grey's anatomy
c'est ma maison bientôt samedi matin des
techniciens débattent pas
je suis
ministre
[Musique]
la voix de l'illusion c'est lui cela
fait 25 ans que vladimir double les plus
grandes stars de cinéma garçons et
filles c'est courant donc en russie de
traduire les films comme ça en direct
oui
et c'est une profession très prisé par
nos spectateurs
les gens préfèrent les traductions fait
en direct
il y en a beaucoup qui n'aiment pas les
sous titres car ils n'ont pas le temps
de
fin la plupart des gens n'ont pas le
temps à la fois de lire les sous titres
et de voir les images et le cinéma c'est
principalement un art visuel et vous
savez depuis quand ça existe en russie
cela remonte aux années 30 alors que
l'union soviétique produisait encore
beaucoup de bons films
mais on recevait également des films
anglais un disque et un américain
français il fallait les traduire pour
nos spectateurs
oui si peu de gens connaissent et les
langues étrangères et c'est comme ça que
l'on a commencé à traduire avec une
seule voie dans les salles de cinéma
travailler
il s'agit d'un film classique
sérieux
avec des acteurs très connus je pense
qu'il vaut mieux ne pas prendre trop de
liberté par rapport à l'original
si c'est une comédie ou un film léger
alors là on adapte des situations
typiquement américaine
pour les faire correspondre à la réalité
russe sont que les spectateurs
comprennent
par exemple si on prend le mot anglais
bien connu fuck si on le traduit
littéralement russe c'est vraiment très
grossier c'est même une insulte
alors qu en anglais c'est simplement
fuck à 26,14 fac
[Musique]
après le son l'image à l'autre bout de
la ville perdure un refuge mythe pour
les amoureux du cinéma le tome kino
autrement dit la maison du cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est là que viennent s'échouer les âmes
perdues du cinéma de l'ère soviétique
[Musique]
ici le temps s'est arrêté sur un âge
d'or les années 60 et 70 une époque
bénie où l'on produisait 150 films par
an
[Musique]
aujourd'hui seulement 40 longs métrages
de fiction sont tournés chaque année en
russie
[Musique]
tandis que les petites dames du
vestiaire attendent la fin de la
projection
de vieille actrice fume sur des canapés
élimé
[Musique]
et c'est dans le café enfumé du premier
étage que les vieux réalisateur se
retrouve alors on bavarde septième art
jusqu'à plus soif
vous en pensez-quoi alors du cinéma
russe d'aujourd'hui
la russie a toujours eu un cinéma qui
avait sa propre personnalité
je suis sûr qu'il n'avait pas son pareil
bien sûr c'était du cinéma soviétique
mais il avait un supplément d'âme et
maintenant ce n'est plus le cas lahm a
disparu c'est un pessimiste
[Musique]
regardez donc les séries à la télévision
et vous ne verrez rien d'autre que du
sang des flics et des crimes
il n'y a pas d'âme dans ces séries
il est passé où le coeur dans tout ça et
pourquoi d'après vous on a toujours
tenté mais le cinéma français c'est
parce qu'il avait du coeur
à l'âme slave mais je suis sûr
vous avez de la jugeote vous le franc
fort
il faut boire cul sec
le cdma russe il ne va pas disparaître
peu à traverser ces cataclysmes mais il
restera en vie
il n'a quoi d'autre choix que de rester
un grand cinéma mais soyez un peu moins
pessimiste quand même un jeu d'accord
voilà
[Musique]
ça ça réchauffe le coeur du coup
l'histoire se poursuit à 1500 km d'ici
là où il fait moins 25 degrés et où voir
des films relève de l'alternatif
une conséquence logique du désoeuvrement
engendrés par les conditions climatiques
l'expérience insolite se vit alors des
deux côtés de l'écran figé entre ici et
nulle part
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
me voici à murmansk la plus grande ville
au nord du cercle arctique
ici l'hiver il ya peu de lumière de la
neige de la glace des sous marins il
fait glacial la ville typique post
soviétique avec industrie à l'abandon et
population alcoolisées qui errent dans
une atmosphère son billet sq
encore un décor idéal pour le cinéma
un homme et une femme marche
main dans la main
il monte un escalier
oh
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà c'est dans ce trou paumé où la fin
du monde semble proche que se taire la
génération périssent troïka la
génération pensante et agissant
librement très loin de toute nostalgie
et de la réalité autoritaire de poutine
lui c'est ostap et redit alcoolisées
quasi aveugle jurant comme un charretier
lui c'est alexander penseurs aux cheveux
longs frisés ensemble ils réalisent des
films de série z avec en toile de fond
un cinéma abandonné
au milieu j'ai des souvenirs d'enfance
qui sont liées à ce lieu c'est ici que
pour la première fois j'ai vu le film
culte cosmico fantastique soviétique à
travers les ronces vers les étoiles
et puis j'aime bien cet endroit
il s'en dégage une atmosphère à la fois
sinistre et envoûtante
[Musique]
yaka
après midi
[Musique]
et
emma film something rauhala le film est
double
il raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme
qui est devenu fou après avoir lu un
livre
il est un peu dingue ils voient des
apparitions et ensuite la figure de
méphistophélès lui apparaît
la scène que nous filmons c'est quand le
jeune homme qui vient d'avoir une
hallucination est pris d'un accès de
folie et décide d'étouffer sa petite
amie mais elle ne se laisse pas faire et
s'échappe enfin ça c'est dans les
grandes lignes
[Musique]
nous puisons notre inspiration dans
différentes sources le cinéma est l'une
d'entre elles
je regarde toutes sortes de films mais
mes films préférés sont les films
d'horreur italien des années 60 à 80
justicière taxi musiciens les films de
dario argento mario bava lucio fulci et
de très nombreux autres
c'est un culte que je vous de manière
très personnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que moi pour être inspiré pour
écrire ou pour inventer des histoires
je regarde des films soviétiques pour
enfants c'est je vois beaucoup de vodka
et après avoir vu disons cinq films dans
la nuit quand j'ai une bonne gueule de
bois alors c'est à ce moment là que les
idées naissent
parce que le cinéma soviétique pour
enfants à vrai dire c'est un truc
terrifiant
ici la fin du tournage est toujours
conditionnée par le froid et la lumière
qui tombe vite
alors toute l'équipe se retrouve dans
l'appartement d'alexander pourparlers
monte h
[Musique]
on les a envoyés dans des festivals on a
aussi l'occasion de les montrer dans des
petites salles n'ont pas changé
mais on fait nos films surtout pour nous
et pour les rares qui souhaite les voir
[Musique]
quand on a filmé les zombies du cercle
polaire c'était le fruit d'une réflexion
sur un certain genre de film les films
de zombies
[Musique]
on a un copain qui avec une critique sur
notre film où il dit qu'il est à peu
près du niveau du film de jean rollin le
lac des morts-vivants
qui nous donnent généralement la palme
du pire film d'horreur de toute
l'histoire des films d'horreur
même si je pense que d'autres films
pourrait rivaliser avec lui
via un maquillage très moche aucun sujet
un jeu d'acteur inexistant mais se fit
nous enchante et le fait qu'on compare
notre film à celui de jean rolin m'a
fait plaisir en plus on nous a dit qu'il
était peut-être même mieux
il ya quelque chose de naïf de spontané
dans cet art qui peut envoûté
bien sûr on peut dire que c'est du
cinéma trash du cinéma poubelles qui n'a
ni queue ni tête et qui a été fait avec
trois francs six sous
pourtant si ce genre de films étaient
réalisées avec les moyens de l'industrie
du cinéma et le résultat ne serait
sûrement pas aussi bon
[Musique]
et le soir à mourmansk c'est dans une
cave que toute cette grouillante
générations se retrouvent
le jeu
ou pas
on y boit on y mange vient écouter ostap
hurlé dans un micro
[Musique]
ouais
mais on vient surtout regarder les
oeuvres de la bande d' alexander
[Musique]
trois femmes
astaro
[Musique]
iris
ce soir
[Musique]
jacques desbois ok
non
[Musique]
montrons
où
bouh
[Musique]
avant je travaillais dans un cinéma à
severomorsk
c'était il ya longtemps quand j'étais
jeune
j'ai fait ça pendant 15
ans suit j'ai projeté des films dans le
ciné club d'une unité militaire
adams coloccini quand j'étais à l'école
louis jeune église c'est vraiment ça je
voulais faire
c'était pas tant que je voulais être
projectionniste mais j'ai mis le cinéma
oblige et pour être le plus proche
possible des films pour en voir autant
que je voulais vous mais choisit ce
métier la fraude et depuis tout ce temps
ce métier continue à me plaire
en règle générale c'est un métier de
femme quand j'ai commencé ce métier il
ya trente ans c'était déjà un métier de
femmes
probablement parce qu'il est mal payé
[Musique]
l'eau
je
les motifs
[Musique]
oui
jorge
lorenzo
s'est passé quoi tient que je suis
si
maintenant les films sont surtout
commerciaux rouste à quoi je n'aime pas
les films de guerre enfin c'est une
affaire de goût gaz métro présent je
voyais tout ce qui sortait ce que ce
soit les films étrangers ou soviétique
il y avait beaucoup de films soviétiques
maintenant ça m'arrive rarement de voir
les films du début à la fin ou bien
plusieurs fois
à l'époque je pouvais voir cinq fois le
même film où au moins mes scènes
préférées
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tandis que la lumière se lève enfin je
quitte cette ville apocalyptique pour me
rendre à 1492 kilomètres de là à la
frontière du kazakhstan
[Musique]
dans les années 20 lénine avait inventé
le ciné train pour montrer des films de
propagande dans les endroits les plus
enfouies du pays
aujourd'hui le parti de poutine russie
unie a repris ce principe en déployant
300 bons petits soldats à travers les
campagnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faux
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de samarra il ne
se passe rien un endroit oublier perdu
un no man's land blanc ici jamais de
cinéma sauf en période électorale avec
le réseau cinéma du peuple
soit une voiture deux filles
[Musique]
et un écran sympa poutine
à
[Musique]
l'instruction ou acidulée qu'il
réussisse à strasbourg ce style
bouscotte paca ce film
je
ne suis pas touché une perche 10e
soutient georges clou du système hybride
vitrifiés des films du squat ou autre à
bordeaux mais si bordeaux gagne
[Musique]
pas
[Applaudissements]
je me suis tanné de se prouver qu'ils
m'ont dit les poudres et chilly
[Musique]
chill et il est mon fou
aujourd'hui pour les habitants du
village ça nous allons montrer le film
la forteresse de brest qui parle d début
de la grande guerre patriotique sur le
territoire de l'urss la ville héroïque
de brest litovsk qui a subi la première
attaque de la part des troupes nazies
et avant le film nous allons projeter un
petit film de propagande
venus pas juste moi ce qu'était le
placide sur glace brut cias
[Musique]
je
précis à visiter tout ça new york ap il
y lit que l'écologie ne seront que 17
nasa mars aux ministres cdh reste à ne
pas saturer séparatisme a ses raisons
pour
lesquelles nous allons nous
[Musique]
préparer
diplomatie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et à la fin de la projection on repart
avec son tract du parti
et une spectatrice a l'air très heureuse
ligne et faciliter aux secousses va pas
quémander werner billets digne
[Musique]
c'est dans un café sordide que j'attends
mon prochain train un voyage se poursuit
à 2073 km d'ici là où paraît-il l'état
russe a décidé que certains films
étaient inutiles une action qui n'est
pas sans rappeler les régimes
totalitaires
[Musique]
me voici à nijni novgorod
et toujours ses décors de grande
désolation
pour pau
c'est dans un immense entrepôt
désaffecté
aux murs décrépis que survive des
milliers de films
classés et très bien empilés sur des
étagères leur sort a été décidé
et c'est à vera qui travaillent ici
depuis 30 ans qu'incombe la lourde tâche
de les trier puis de les jeter
soda paris j'y aille au bout d'à priori
une fast and
[Musique]
speed et reuben hitchcock
attendiez l'apprenez
[Musique]
j'te lire dans la presse
ouais ouais tu vas vite de ce concours
est pour lui c'est victor le patron de
vera
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que deux à
travailler ici rires ce qu'aucune 10h
aux compétitions
lucho ayew
niimi comme tous les petits actionnaires
nous lisent aujourd'hui on trouve tout
sur internet
mais imaginez un peu qu'on prenne une
bibliothèque etc on brûle tous les
livres
pourquoi pas parce que pour les mêmes
petits fonctionnaires tout est sur
internet
quel que soit le livre que tu cherches
il suffit de cliquer sur un bouton et tu
le trouves
alors on va brûler les bibliothèques
je
m
le
[Musique]
je sauverai 6 acquittement
caxton se dote
soit
prévoyez pour virer
cavaillon
malgré tout et comme si de rien n'était
vera s'accroche et continue de faire son
travail en vérifiant l'état des derniers
films sauver figurant sur la liste
[Musique]
tous des films de fictions russes
[Applaudissements]
quant aux tableaux de privilèges sont
performants
[Musique]
ces films ou des stores liés à l'excès
par pis
voilà tous ceux là vont être conservés
ils ont été bien rangé ils vont prendre
ses 1500 films mais où est-ce qu'ils
vont les mettre
yanis dans une cave
franchement je ne sais pas c'est très
peu probable qu'il mette de l'argent
là-dedans j'ai vraiment des doutes
lorsque tout ça ça demande des dépenses
c'est à dire de l'argent